when I was 28 years old I was a
millionaire making $250,000 a year but I
had done a lot of stupid stuff ever done
something stupid with money yeah I've
done a lot of stupid stuff with money I
borrowed too much money and the bank got
sold to another bank and they called her
notes and a brand new baby toddler a
young marriage I was so scared I
couldn't breathe I didn't know what to
do you ever been there I remember
distinctly and it's 30 years ago I still
remember distinctly trying to balance
the checkbook now this is old school
there was no internet so I had the
little checkbook register out with my
calculator and I was trying to balance
the checkbook and I realized I had not
entered a check meaning that I had
operated off of a false balance and I
was going into overdraft and there's
gonna be overdraft charges in the cheque
was gonna bounce you know you know that
feeling my heart rate changes a little
sweat right on the top of your upper lip
right above your eyebrows and summer in
the palm of your hand it's called stress
fear anxiety looking at the mountain of
bills piled up on the desk can't breathe
they
I'm gonna sit down and talk to my wife
and say that money I thought we have for
groceries it's not there what are we
gonna do they're going to cut the lights
off on Tuesday honey Electric Company's
coming on Tuesday the net last notice of
the last notice of the last notice as an
outcome since it's the third time
they're cutting off the electricity this
time they're going to take the meter out
and it's going to cost us an extra
several hundred dollars to get it put
back in yeah I know it's cold outside I
know we have babies to keep warm you
ever had those kinds of discussions
those conversations I hope you never do
but most people have some degree or
another maybe you didn't know millions
of dollars and maybe you weren't stupid
as I was maybe you were slightly stupid
as compared to my PhD in D UMB but if
you've ever done something really dumb
and been so scared you couldn't breathe
you're listening to the right show
that's why I start doing this radio show
to take people that were like that and
show them how to get their feet back
under them and actually become wealthy
and live their dreams go from
stressed-out and can't breathe with my
heart racing to multi-millionaire with
my family tree changed to where I'm the
last Ramsey in this branch of the tree
that will have to worry about money my
kids and my grandkids have really got to
screw this up to go through how much
money we've piled up now because when I
hit that bottom I hit it so hard I said
never again not only am I going to never
again sit here and have this
conversation inside my head not only am
I gonna have to have this conversation
with my wife this is it it stops here
with the Ramsey family this branch of
the tree it stops here as for me and my
house we're gonna serve the Lord it
stops here as for me and my house we
don't borrow money anymore ever for any
thing because you see when you don't
have any payments it's fairly easy to
build wealth when you don't have any
payments your stress level goes almost
to zero when you don't have any payments
you're able to give and be generous and
not even think about it you don't have
to worry when you're not broke about
your generosity you're not making a
choice between taking care of your own
household first or being generous when
you're not broke you can do both but
it's an intentional act to not be broke
you can get broke by no fault of your
own or you can get broke like I did a
fault of your own sometimes things
happen to you that are out of your
control and it's not your fault staying
there however is your fault
staying there would have been my fault
but I said never again never again at
our fifth grandchild born this week
never again
he will not have that experience the
only way he'll have that experience is
if he misbehaves and gets cut out of the
family fortune because he's gonna be
okay if he behaves he's covered and his
brother
sister and his two cousins they're
covered because I said never again you
can say never again you can decide to
change your family tree starting right
now if you're sitting there like that
lady who started the show off today from
Idaho she's so scared with a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars in debt and a
forty thousand dollar income and brand
new jobs just got those jobs and they're
not even great jobs and she's scared
overwhelmed can't breathe if that's you
it'll take you some time it'll be hard
no discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
but I will make you a promise if you
will live like no one else I will show
you how that by living like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else you can not only change your life
you can not only change your destiny not
only change the quality of your
retirement personally but you can change
your entire family tree and if you
really want to think big you can get
yourself in a position to change your
community with your generosity and never
miss a dime of it what if you could give
away millions of dollars a year could
you do some good with that there's a
prerequisite to that you'd have to first
have millions of dollars a year tada
here's the trick anyone can do it I
don't care what your education level is
I don't care what your background is I
don't care where you come from how your
family acted I don't care what your race
is I I don't care I have met people of
every region background race education
level that have turned this financial
thing around by a sheer act of their
will
some get a head start based on the
family they come from the education
that's provided to them some get a head
start based on their race some get a
head start based on their
sex but just cuz you got a head start
doesn't mean you can't run the race just
because somebody else got a head start
doesn't mean you can't run the race is
it harder for some than others yes some
of us aren't as smart as some of you
makes it harder when you're dumb but
when you're dumb and you keep doing dumb
things that's just stupid that's
different than just not having the raw
material that just means I'm making bad
choices
so I don't know how you got there and
I'm not blaming you for being there but
five years from now if you're still
there that's your fault because I can
show you how to get out step by step
I've shown millions millions and
millions of families how to turn their
financial life around get out of debt
and be on the road to being millionaires
meaning that you changed your family
tree and you insured your financial
destiny for retirement I know some of
you are scared been there done that got
the t-shirt let's trade it for a
different t-shirt or you say this is the
Dave Ramsey show